Willkommen zurück bei Quantum Computing in Practice. Das ist Episode 6. Heute konzentrieren wir uns auf eine meiner liebsten
Anwendungen von Quantencomputern: die Simulation der Natur. In dieser Episode besprechen wir die Schritte, die nötig sind,
um das für beliebige Quantendynamik-Probleme umzusetzen – also das Problem, herauszufinden, wie sich die Beschreibung eines
Quantensystems mit der Zeit verändert. Wir machen das zunächst auf einer allgemeinen Ebene und schauen uns dann ein konkretes Beispiel an und gehen
es im Detail durch – nämlich das IBM-Experiment von 2023, das den Quantennutzen demonstriert hat. Als kurze Motivation am
Anfang: eine der bekanntesten Geschichten, die wir im Bereich Quantencomputing immer wieder erzählen,
ist die Geschichte von Richard Feynman, der 1959 einen Vortrag am Caltech hielt und dabei im Grunde
die Motivation für das gesamte Feld für Jahrzehnte lieferte. Der Vortrag hieß „There's Plenty of Room at the
Bottom" – ein witziger Titel, aber die Grundidee war, dass er behauptete, auf mikroskopischer Ebene gebe es noch so viel reiche Physik zu
entdecken.
Dieser spezifische Vortrag fand damals wenig Beachtung, bis in den 80ern die Technologie erheblich fortgeschritten war. Und Feynman
präzisierte und verfeinerte seine Botschaft auch im Laufe der Zeit. Er kehrte in den 80ern ans Caltech zurück und präsentierte eine weitere Arbeit mit dem Titel
„Simulating Physics with Computers", in der er explizit sagte, er wolle über die Möglichkeit sprechen, dass es eine
exakte Simulation gibt, bei der der Computer genau dasselbe tut wie die Natur.
Im Wesentlichen geht es darum, grobe Näherungen dessen, was auf atomarer Ebene passiert, loszuwerden und sie durch
Computer zu ersetzen, die Quantenphysik verstehen und nutzen – nicht nur, um das nachzuahmen, was die Natur tut, sondern um es zu emulieren.
Erinnere dich an diese Zeitleisten-Grafik, die ich in einer früheren Episode gezeigt habe. An einem Ende hatten wir Probleme, die einfach zu
lösen sind und keinerlei Beschleunigung benötigen, die Quantencomputing bieten könnte. Aber am anderen Ende haben wir Probleme, die
sehr schwer sind und fehlertolerante Quantenmaschinen benötigen, die wir noch nicht haben.
Glücklicherweise glauben wir, dass es einige Simulationsprobleme gibt, die hier in der Mitte liegen – also in dem Bereich, in dem wir
derzeit arbeiten können. Und es gibt viele Gründe, von dieser Aussicht begeistert und fasziniert zu sein, denn die
Simulation der Natur ist die Grundlage für viele spannende Anwendungsbereiche – um nur ein paar zu nennen. Wenn wir die Natur besser
simulieren könnten, könnten wir die Entdeckung neuer Materialien beschleunigen, bessere Pharmaka und Medikamente entwickeln oder
sogar neue Physik der Teilchenphysik oder Kosmologie erforschen. Aber bevor du oder ich oder irgendjemand versuchen kann,
Quantencomputing auf diese aufregenden Bereiche anzuwenden, müssen sie zunächst die grundlegenden Schritte in einem
typischen simulationsbasierten Workflow verstehen.
Zuerst möchtest du ein Quantensystem von Interesse identifizieren. Das gibt dir Aufschluss über den Hamilton-Operator, der seine Zeitentwicklung
steuert, sowie eine sinnvolle Beschreibung seiner Anfangseigenschaften oder seines Zustands.
Dann musst du eine geeignete Methode finden, um die Zeitentwicklung dieses Zustands umzusetzen. Wenn diese Zutaten
geklärt sind, umfassen die nächsten Schritte die Durchführung des eigentlichen Experiments.
Dabei geht es im Allgemeinen darum, die circuit-Implementierung des Zeitentwicklungsalgorithmus zu optimieren und die
circuits auf Quantenhardware auszuführen und die Ergebnisse nachzuverarbeiten. Wir können also
die grundlegenden Schritte eines Simulationsexperiments wie folgt benennen.
Identifikation des System-Hamiltonians, Hamilton-Enkodierung, Zustandspräparation, Zustandsentwicklung,
circuit-Optimierung, circuit-Ausführung und Nachbearbeitung.
Das sind ziemlich detaillierte Schritte. Denk daran, dass die vier Phasen des Qiskit-Patterns-Frameworks, das uns hilft
zu verstehen, wie man eine Routine in Qiskit implementiert, Folgende sind: Mapping, circuit-Optimierung, circuit-Ausführung und
Nachbearbeitung. Diese ersten vier Schritte hier fallen also alle unter den Oberbegriff des Mappings – und das ist
der Grund, warum wir eine ganze Episode dieser ersten Phase gewidmet haben. Falls du die verpasst hast, schau bitte zurück und sieh dir die vorherige Episode an.
Lass uns zunächst durchgehen, was diese Schritte überhaupt bedeuten, bevor wir uns mit dem Programmieren befassen. Das erste Grundlegende, was wir
tun müssen, um ein Simulationsexperiment durchzuführen, ist den Hamilton-Operator zu identifizieren, der das System beschreibt. Manchmal –
meistens – sind diese bekannt, manchmal müssen wir ihn aus dem Verständnis der Energiebeiträge
kleiner Teilmengen des Gesamtsystems zusammensetzen, also so, wobei hi der Hamilton-Operator ist, der auf eines der n Teilsysteme von h wirkt.
Wir müssen auch beachten, ob das System aus Fermionen oder Bosonen besteht, wenn wir es mit Elementarteilchen zu tun haben. Als Nächstes
müssen wir den Hamilton-Operator enkodieren und in Begriffe übersetzen, die Quantencomputer verstehen können. Oft
bestehen diese Hamiltonians aus Elementarteilchen oder Spin-Systemen. Wenn wir Fermionen oder Bosonen simulieren,
müssen wir eine Enkodierungstransformation wählen, wie die Jordan-Wigner- oder Bravyi-Kitaev-Transformation. Diese Transformationen
zeigen uns, wie wir die Definition des Hamiltonians, geschrieben in den ursprünglichen Komponenten – also den Fermionen oder
Bosonen – in Pauli-Operatoren übersetzen, die sich leicht in gates auf einem Quantencomputer umwandeln lassen. Die Jordan-Wigner-
Transformation zum Beispiel, die hier definiert ist, liefert eine Abbildung von Fermionenoperatoren auf Pauli-Operatoren. Wenn wir es bereits mit
Spin-1/2-Systemen zu tun haben – die sehr verbreitet sind –, dann sind wir abgesehen von möglichen Normierungskoeffizienten startklar
und brauchen kein Enkodierungsschema zu verwenden. Nachdem wir den gewünschten Hamilton-Operator in das gate-Set des Quantencomputers enkodiert haben,
ist der nächste entscheidende Schritt, den geeigneten anfänglichen Quantenzustand zu bestimmen, von dem aus wir unsere
Simulation starten. Dieser Zustand sollte idealerweise eine physikalische Bedeutung oder Konfiguration des
untersuchten Systems widerspiegeln. Wenn wir zum Beispiel die Grundzustandsenergie eines Moleküls erforschen wollen, beginnen wir vielleicht
mit einer Hartree-Fock-Näherung oder einer anderen leicht präparierbaren, die eine signifikante Überlappung mit dem tatsächlichen
Grundzustand hat. Die Wahl des anfänglichen Grundzustands beeinflusst nicht nur die Konvergenz von Variationsalgorithmen
wie VQE, dem Variational Quantum Eigensolver, sondern auch die Genauigkeit und Effizienz der
Zeitentwicklung oder des Samplings in der Quantenphasenschätzung. Im Wesentlichen dient der Anfangszustand als
Startpunkt der Berechnung und legt die Bühne dafür fest, nützliche Observablen über das Quantensystem
zu extrahieren, das wir modellieren. Die Präparation eines beliebigen n-qubit-Zustands, wobei ci die Berechnungsbasiszustände und ai die
jeweiligen Koeffizienten jedes Zustands sowie die Normierungsbedingung 2 hoch n minus eins sind, kann im Allgemeinen so angegangen werden:
Man initialisiert den Zustand mit dem Operator o, der Ausgangszustand wäre der vollständige Null-Standardbasiszustand, oft so geschrieben
zur Vereinfachung. Im Allgemeinen erfordert das eine exponentielle Anzahl von CNOT-gates – oft sind wir
an einem bestimmten Anfangszustand für das System interessiert, und dessen Präparation kann mit einem angemessenen Aufwand
an Ressourcen umgesetzt werden. Produktzustände zum Beispiel, bei denen die qubits nicht miteinander verschränkt sind, benötigen nur einzelne
qubit-Operationen. Jetzt hatten wir noch keine Gelegenheit, über Trotterisierung zu sprechen,
obwohl einige von euch damit wahrscheinlich schon vertraut sind. Im Wesentlichen ist Trotterisierung eine Methode zur Berechnung von Matrixexponentiation, die
Näherungen nutzt, um die exponentielle Natur von nicht-kommutierenden Operatoren zu handhaben. Wenn zwei Operatoren wie HA
und HB nicht kommutieren, müssen wir einen cleveren Trick anwenden und abwechselnd die entsprechenden Exponentialterme
e hoch -i HA und e hoch -i HB für n Mal
anwenden. Die abwechselnden Entwicklungsoperatoren werden angewendet. Ich werde den Beweis hier nicht durchgehen, aber ich teile einen Link
zu einem schönen, einfachen Beweis dieser Aussage in der Beschreibung. Die wichtigste Botschaft ist folgende: Zeitentwicklung ist ein
wichtiger Teil des Mappings. Trotterisierung zerlegt eine kontinuierliche Wechselwirkung in diskrete Schritte, die
auf einem Quantencomputer implementiert werden können. Nach der Erzeugung des trotterisierten circuit haben wir den
Mapping-Schritt abgeschlossen. Wir können jetzt mit der circuit-Optimierung fortfahren.
Dafür muss Folgendes erreicht werden: Es wird ein qubit-Layout benötigt, das die virtuellen qubits des
circuit den physischen auf der Hardware zuordnet. Das ist nötig, weil Hardware bestimmte Topologien haben kann,
die die direkte Wechselwirkung physischer qubits einschränken. Während die Implementierung eines
quantum circuit oft die Fähigkeit voraussetzt, dass jedes qubit mit jedem anderen qubit interagieren kann. Dann müssen wir
swap gates nach Bedarf einfügen, um Wechselwirkungen zwischen qubits weiterzuleiten, die nicht verbunden sind. Wir müssen die
gates in unserem circuit in Befehlssatzarchitektur- oder ISA-Anweisungen übersetzen, die
direkt auf der Hardware ausgeführt werden können. Dann müssen wir circuit-Optimierungen durchführen, um die
circuit-Tiefe und die Anzahl der gates zu minimieren. Dieser Schritt kann auch auf dem virtuellen circuit durchgeführt werden. Der circuit, bei dem die qubits
noch nicht auf eine Gerätetopologie gemappt wurden. Bedenke aber, dass vieles davon in
Qiskit automatisch für dich erledigt wird. Im nächsten Abschnitt dieser Vorlesung werden wir genau sehen, wie. Nach dem Optimierungsschritt sind wir bereit,
den circuit mit einem Primitive auszuführen. Bei den meisten Simulationsexperimenten interessierst du dich dafür, die Veränderung
bestimmter Eigenschaften des Systems mit der Zeit zu verstehen. Es ist daher wahrscheinlich, dass du den Estimator-Primitive verwenden wirst, weil er
dir erlaubt, die Erwartungswerte von Observablen zu messen, die bestimmten Eigenschaften entsprechen. Dann werden wir
die besten Optionen für den Estimator konfigurieren, was Fehlerunterdrückungs- und Fehlerminderungstechniken hinzufügen kann. Abschließend werden wir das
Experiment ausführen. Der letzte Schritt ist die Nachverarbeitung aller Daten. Dabei werden die gemessenen Erwartungswerte extrahiert oder, falls
du den Sampler verwendest, die Stichproben-Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilung in der Rechenbasis. Wenn alles, was man braucht,
die Erwartungswerte der interessierenden Observablen sind, können diese direkt vom Estimator
Primitive sowohl in ihren rohen als auch in fehlergeminderten Werten erhalten werden. Häufig werden dann die gemessenen Erwartungswerte
für weitere Berechnungen anderer interessierender Größen verwendet, die keine Quantenberechnung erfordern und
auf einem klassischen Computer berechnet werden können.
Jetzt werden wir ein reales Beispiel aus einem sehr einflussreichen Paper durchgehen, das IBM vor einigen Jahren veröffentlicht hat, mit dem Titel
„Evidence for utility of quantum computing before fault tolerance". Dieses Paper, das wir liebevoll als
das Utility-Paper abkürzen, wurde fast unmittelbar nach seiner Veröffentlichung zu einem sehr einflussreichen Paper im Bereich des quantum computing.
Die übergeordnete These des Papers ist, dass ein verrauschter Quantencomputer genaue Ergebnisse bzw. Erwartungswerte
mit 127 qubits und 2.880 gates lieferte, die außerhalb der Möglichkeiten der Brute-
Force-Berechnung liegen, also der exakten Simulation der vom Hardware ausgeführten quantum circuits. Diese Arbeit war
auch wichtig, weil sie zeigte, dass ein Quantencomputer genutzt werden kann, um Ergebnisse mit anderen
näherungsweisen klassischen Methoden für Quantensimulationen zu verifizieren oder zu vergleichen, wie etwa Tensornetzwerk-Algorithmen, bei denen die Lösung
nicht von vornherein bekannt war. Ziemlich cool ist auch, dass andere jetzt die IBM-Quantensysteme
in der Cloud und Qiskit nutzen können, um diese Ergebnisse selbst zu reproduzieren und zu verifizieren.
Ich werde dir zeigen, wie das geht. Für dieses Beispiel werden wir etwas konkreter auf die
Schritte eingehen, die beim Mapping dieses Problems in Eingaben involviert sind, die von einem Quantengerät verstanden werden können. In diesem Fall werden wir
die Dynamik der Gesamtmagnetisierung eines Systems magnetischer Dipolspins auf einem Gitter in
Anwesenheit eines externen Magnetfeldes simulieren. Das System kann durch ein Ising-Modell mit transversalem Magnetfeld beschrieben werden.
Wir modellieren dies mit einem parametrisierten quantum circuit, bei dem die Parameter dem einstellbaren Wert des
Spin-Spin- oder Z-Wechselwirkung und der Stärke des Magnetfeldes X entsprechen. Jetzt,
diese Reihe heißt „Quantum Computing in Practice". Daher werden wir auch Verfahren in diesem Experiment besprechen,
die wir implementieren werden, um die Ergebnisse so gut wie möglich zu machen. Als nächstes werden wir besprechen, wie man
schlechte qubits oder qubits mit niedriger gate-Güte oder kurzen Dekohärenzzeiten entfernt, was die
experimentellen Ergebnisse drastisch beeinflussen könnte. Diese schlechten qubits können durch mangelhafte vorherige Kalibrierung
oder Zwei-Niveau-Systeme, die mit dem qubit wechselwirken, entstehen. Das Entfernen einiger qubits aus der hardware-nativen Topologie entspricht der
Betrachtung eines Systems auf einem Gitter, das durch die resultierende Topologie beschrieben wird. Wir werden auch die Erstellung des
parametrisierten quantum circuit besprechen, der die Zeitentwicklung des Systems via Trotterisierung implementiert.
Dafür wird es wichtig sein, verschränkende Schichten zu identifizieren, die ein kritischer Teil der wichtigsten Fehler-
minderungstechnik sind, die wir später verwenden werden. An diesem Punkt möchte ich sicherstellen, dass du, das Publikum, weißt,
dass du allem, was ich gleich bespreche, im unten verlinkten Tutorial und auf der IBM
Quantum Learning Platform folgen kannst. In diesem Tutorial wirst du vielleicht feststellen, dass wir eine Reihe von Hilfsfunktionen
zu Beginn des Notebooks erstellt haben, auf die wir später zurückgreifen können, um uns das Leben etwas leichter zu machen. Ich möchte diese
jetzt erwähnen, nicht weil es Teil des offiziellen oder formalen Prozesses ist, sondern weil das oft das ist, was Experimentatoren
im realen Leben tun, um diese Art von Experimenten durchzuführen. Und es zeigt uns auch, wie wir unser
Problem noch weiter aufteilen werden. Die Funktionen, die wir im Notebook definieren, sind folgende: qubit-Kopplungen entfernen.
qubit-Kopplungen definieren. Die Schichtkopplungen konstruieren. Verschränkende Schichten konstruieren. Und zuletzt, den trotterisierten
circuit definieren. Als nächstes sprechen wir über Schichtkopplungen, die dabei helfen zu definieren, wie qubits
während der Simulation mit ihren Nachbarn interagieren. Unsere Quantengeräte verwenden etwas, das als schweres hexagonales
Layout bezeichnet wird. Ein spezielles Muster zum Verbinden von qubits. In diesem Layout können wir die Verbindungen, sogenannte Kanten, in drei
getrennte Mengen gruppieren, bei denen keine zwei Verbindungen in derselben Menge ein qubit teilen. Das ist
wichtig, weil wir auf einem echten Quantencomputer keine Zwei-qubit-gates gleichzeitig ausführen können, wenn sie dasselbe
qubit beinhalten. Jedes qubit kann jeweils nur an einem gate beteiligt sein. Indem wir
alle Verbindungen in drei Schichten aufteilen, können wir Zwei-qubit-gates über das gesamte Gerät in drei
Runden anwenden und sicherstellen, dass kein qubit in mehr als einem gate pro Schicht verwendet wird. Diese
gates implementieren die ZZ-Wechselwirkung aus dem Ising-Modell und werden bei jedem Schritt der Simulation wiederholt, dem sogenannten
Trotter-Schritt. Twirling verändert das Rauschen im Gerät so, dass selbst ein einfaches Rauschmodell
wahrscheinlich genau ist. Das macht es auch möglich, das Rauschmodell genau zu erlernen und die gewonnenen
Informationen in Fehlerminderungstechniken zu nutzen.
Als nächstes müssen wir unsere schlechten qubits aus unserer möglichen Liste physischer qubits entfernen, die wir für das
Experiment verwenden können. Wie gesagt, ein qubit kann aus verschiedenen Gründen schlecht werden. Manchmal ist es einfach eine schlechte
Kalibrierung, ein einfacher Fehler, der sich durch erneutes Kalibrieren beheben lässt.
Manchmal ist es etwas komplizierter und hängt mit etwas zusammen, das wir ein TLS nennen, ein Zwei-Niveau-Grenzflächen-
Defekt, der zu qubit-Parameterfluktuationen und Relaxation führt. Das lässt sich
beheben, indem man das gesamte System ein wenig aufwärmt und es dann wieder abkühlt. Aber das dauert eine Weile und ist nicht möglich,
das über die Cloud zu tun. Daher ist es im Moment am einfachsten, sie einfach aus unserer Liste möglicher physischer
qubits, die wir verwenden werden, auszuschließen. Auf der IBM Quantum Platform kannst du leicht erkennen, welche qubits sich nicht wie erwartet verhalten.
Du kannst die qubit-Eigenschaften dort auf der Plattform darstellen oder sie als CSV herunterladen. Erstelle dann eine Liste aller
qubits, die du ausschließen möchtest, und entferne sie einfach aus der Liste der gesamten physischen qubits auf dem Gerät.
Gut. Fahren wir nun mit unserem Mapping-Schritt fort und generieren unseren trotterisierten circuit. Wie wir bereits gezeigt haben,
diskretisiert die Trotterisierung die Zeitentwicklung in eine Reihe von Schritten, und wir müssen entscheiden, wie viele Schritte.
Wir wählen hier sechs. Aber generell besteht die Strategie darin, den sogenannten Trotter-Fehler, der ein
algorithmischer Approximationsfehler ist, mit dem durch Dekohärenz entstehenden Fehler auszubalancieren. Mehr Trotter-Schritte reduzieren den Approximations-
fehler, erfordern aber tiefere quantum circuits, die mehr Dekohärenzrauschen ausgesetzt sind. Wir werden den
circuit in Bezug auf den Theta-Parameter definieren, der die Stärke des externen Magnetfelds, die Schichtkopplungen und die
Anzahl der Schritte und qubits sowie natürlich das Gerät-backend angibt. Aufgrund der
Abhängigkeit der Magnetisierung des Systems von der Stärke des externen Magnetfelds ist es interessant,
die Simulation bei verschiedenen Werten der Magnetfeldstärke durchzuführen, die sich in unterschiedliche Winkel von RX bei
der Rotation für RX im circuit übersetzen. Nachdem wir unseren circuit generiert haben, fahren wir nun mit seiner Optimierung fort.
Der erste Schritt hier besteht darin, einen Pass Manager zu definieren. Im Kontext des Qiskit SDK bezeichnet Transpilation den
Prozess der Umwandlung eines Eingabe-circuits in eine Form, die für die Ausführung auf einem Quantengerät geeignet ist.
Transpilation erfolgt typischerweise in einer Abfolge von Schritten, die transpiler passes genannt werden. Ein Pass Manager ist ein Objekt, das
eine Liste von transpiler passes speichert und sie auf einem circuit ausführen kann. Erstelle einen Pass Manager, indem du ein Pass-
Manager-Objekt mit einer Liste von transpiler passes initialisierst. Am Ende wird unser Pass Manager
einen ISA-circuit erstellen, einen circuit, der in Form der Instruction Set Architecture des backend geschrieben werden muss,
welche den circuit und die gates beschreibt, die nativ für das backend sind, aber die zur Ausführung des
circuits benötigten Zeitinformationen fehlen. Nun sind wir bereit, unseren circuit auszuführen, was Schritt drei der Qiskit-Patterns ist. Wie bereits erwähnt, werden wir
hier definitiv den Estimator als unser bevorzugtes Primitiv für dieses Experiment verwenden, da wir die
Gesamtmagnetisierung des Systems messen möchten, und die Schätzung des Erwartungswerts der Observablen ist das, wofür der Estimator
entwickelt wurde. In diesem Schritt wird es auch entscheidend sein, unsere Optionen zur Fehlerminderung festzulegen. Wir werden Zero-Noise-
Extrapolation verwenden, um bestmögliche Ergebnisse zu erzielen. Insbesondere im Tutorial wirst du sehen, dass wir zwei oder mehr
Rauschfaktorwerte angeben, bei denen die extrapolierten Modelle ausgewertet werden sollen, und
probabilistic error amplification als unsere Amplifikationsoption festlegen. Nun, probabilistic
error amplification oder PA war hier wirklich die Fehlerminderungstechnik der Wahl, weil sie so viel
besser skaliert als die anderen Optionen. Und das ist wichtig, wenn wir auf der Ebene von 100 und mehr qubits arbeiten.
Zu guter Letzt: Führe das Experiment aus – es wird einige Zeit in Anspruch nehmen – aber lass uns jetzt die
im Tutorial in der Warteschlange gespeicherten Daten nutzen. Wir werden die Metadaten untersuchen und dabei die geschichteten gates und
die geminderten Schichten besonders beachten, da wir diese gleich verwenden werden, um eine Reihe von Fehlern aus unseren Rohdaten zu entfernen. Wir sind fast bereit,
unsere Endergebnisse darzustellen. Aber bevor wir das tun, lass uns hier kurz ein Interlude einfügen darüber, was genau mit Zero-
Noise-Extrapolation oder ZNE gemeint ist. Wir haben es kurz in früheren Episoden besprochen, aber zur Wiederholung: Zero-Noise-Extrapolation
ist eine Fehlerminderungstechnik, die die Auswirkungen eines unbekannten Rauschens während der circuit-Ausführung beseitigt, das
auf bekannte Weise skaliert werden kann. Sie geht davon aus, dass Erwartungswerte mit dem Rauschen durch eine bekannte Funktion skalieren, die hier gezeigt wird, wobei die
Lambda-Parameter die Rauschstärke angeben und verstärkt werden können. Wir können ZNE mit den folgenden Schritten implementieren.
Zunächst wird das circuit-Rauschen für mehrere Rauschfaktoren verstärkt. Lambda 1, Lambda 2,
Lambda 3 und so weiter. Führe jeden rauschverstärkten circuit aus, um den
Erwartungswert a von Lambda 1, a von Lambda 2 usw. zu messen. Und extrapoliere dann zurück zum Zero-Noise-
Limit, dem Erwartungswert a von null.
Die größte Herausforderung bei der erfolgreichen Implementierung von ZNE besteht darin, ein genaues Modell für das Rauschen im Erwartungswert
zu haben und das Rauschen auf bekannte Weise zu verstärken.
Es gibt drei gängige Methoden, wie Fehlerverstärkung für ZNE implementiert wird: Pulsdauer über Kalibrierung skalieren,
gates in Identitätszyklen wiederholen und Rauschen über Sampling-Pauli-Kanäle hinzufügen.
Wir nennen Letzteres PA. Probabilistic error amplification ist hier die beste Wahl, weil Pulse-Stretching sehr
rechenaufwendig ist. Gate-Folding bietet keine theoretischen Garantien für die Beibehaltung des Rauschbias. Aber PA kann auf
jeden circuit angewendet werden, der mit nativen Rauschfaktoren ausgeführt werden kann, erfordert aber das Erlernen des Rauschmodells. PA setzt das
gleiche schichtbasierte Rauschmodell wie probabilistic error cancellation voraus.
Es vermeidet jedoch den Sampling-Overhead, der exponentiell mit dem circuit-Rauschen skaliert. Um das Rauschmodell zu erlernen,
müssen wir zunächst die eindeutigen Schichten von Zwei-qubit-Operationen im circuit identifizieren.
Für jede Schicht werden die Zwei-qubit-gates pauli-getwirlt, um sicherzustellen, dass das Rauschen gut durch ein Dämpfungsrauschmodell beschrieben wird.
Identitätspaare von Schichten in variabler Tiefe wiederholen und schließlich eine Fidelity oder einen Fehler für jeden Rauschkanal fitten. Und
natürlich empfehle ich zwar, diese Methode bis zu einem gewissen Grad zu verstehen, aber sie in Qiskit von Hand zu implementieren ist
viel einfacher, wie im Tutorial gezeigt wird. Schauen wir uns jetzt endlich die dargestellten Daten an. Die gepunktete
graue Linie zeigt die genauen Ergebnisse, die mit approximativen klassischen Methoden mit Approximationsfehler erhalten wurden,
der gegen einen niedrigen Schwellenwert konvergiert. Wie du sehen kannst, liegen die Rohdaten für die verschiedenen Rauschfaktoren, die wir zu Beginn
gewählt haben, deutlich von dieser gepunkteten Linie entfernt. Die durchgehend blaue Linie zeigt die Daten unter Berücksichtigung unserer ZNE-
Verarbeitung. Und man kann sofort erkennen, dass sie den genauen Ergebnissen viel näher ist.
Zusammenfassend zeigen die verrauschten Werte eine hohe Abweichung von den genauen Werten. Die
geminderten Werte liegen nahe an den genauen Werten und demonstrieren den Nutzen der PA-basierten Minderungstechnik.
Damit ist diese Episode im Wesentlichen abgeschlossen. Um kurz zusammenzufassen, was wir gelernt haben: Quantensimulation ist eine
der vielversprechendsten Anwendungsbereiche auf kurze bis mittlere Sicht.
Sie hat weitreichende Anwendungen von der Pharmaindustrie bis zur Hochenergiephysik,
Materialwissenschaft und mehr. Das Utility-Paper von IBM, das 2023 veröffentlicht wurde, wies
den Weg hin zu der Möglichkeit, Quantencomputer für wissenschaftliche Entdeckungen zu nutzen. Und wir haben das
zugehörige Tutorial, das zu diesem Paper gehört, eingehend durchgearbeitet. Die Schritte zur Bearbeitung eines Simulationsproblems von Anfang
bis Ende sind relativ unkompliziert, besonders wenn man den Dreh raus hat. Und ich hoffe, dass du
von nun an dieses Video und das Tutorial als Leitfaden für noch mehr Simulationsprobleme in der Zukunft nutzen kannst.
Danke fürs Zuschauen, und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal bei Quantum Computing in Practice.